my appeal to all the intellectuals to
all the men and women of culture and to
all citizens is not to give up to this
defeatism to have the courage to find
the negative forces yes because the
populistic forces the extremist forces
are negative forces that are today under
a team that very often is an ant
European team making the revival of the
old demons of Europe like extreme
nationalism like Zimmy phobia sometimes
racism these are negative values and it
is important in face of this challenge
instead of keeping ourselves in the
comfort zone namely so-called
establishment parties to have the
courage to go out and fight not to give
up to those arguments to explain with
reasonable and rational arguments
sometimes for some of us with emotional
why we care about you why Europe is
something we must cherish precisely to
defend these values and if sometimes in
Europe some of us have doubts about our
important these values have hard just to
Ukraine those young people in the
streets of Ukraine by freezing
temperatures are writing the new
narrative for Europe
when we see in the cold streets of Kiev
men and women with your pin flag
fighting for that European flag is
because they are also fighting for
Ukraine and for their future because
they know that Europe is not just the
land of opportunity in terms of economic
development because they have seen what
happened in Poland or what happened in
the Baltic countries but also because
Europe is the promise of hope and
freedom and I think new European Union
has the right and the duty to stand by
the people of Ukraine in this very
difficult moment because they are giving
to Europe one of the greatest
contributions that can be given just
yesterday I had a phone call another one
with President Yanukovych I've asked him
to show restraint in face of this recent
development to use not to force against
the people that are demonstrating
peacefully to respectfully the freedoms
that are so important for all of us in
Europe I've asked him to receive high
representative vice president of the
Commission Cassie ersten that will be in
Kiev already tomorrow and the day after
tomorrow so that she can also have a
role in trying to bring some solutions
to that very tense situation that
Ukraine is living today and I hope that
European forces will show their
commitment to our Comment project
because it's not true that it is only in
the western part of Ukraine know most of
the Ukrainians care about the future in
peace and freedom and I think we have
this duty to recognize them today
because precisely our history is a
history of openness